Oh, willkommen, willkommen, willkommen, Podcast UFO, wir packen unsere sieben Sachen hin. Sorry. Und ich sag, ey, Podcast UFO, den Lachern hinterher, ey, oh was geht, den Lachern hinterher, ey, oh was geht, und ich sag, hey, Leute, herzlich willkommen zu Folge 1 nach Jan Bimacken. Sommer, Sommer, geil!
Sommer, Sommer, Sonnenschein!
Sommer, Sommer, herzlich willkommen zu Folge 1 nach Jan Bimak. Sommer, Sommer, geil. Sommer, Sommer, Sommer, Sommer. Auch weil dieses Lied keinen Hehl darum macht, keinen Songtext zu haben, sondern die ganz einfach so zehn Minuten Sommer, Sommer, Sommer, Sonnenschein, einfach so durchzieht, so penetrant, aber es geht ins Ohr. Ah, ich liebe einfach Sommer, schön raus, den Bikini über die Schulter geworfen, schön den Grill angemacht, die Beachparty. Oh, Sand, wer hat da wen im Sand eingegraben? Oh, das Meer. Oh, wir haben Sand im Schuh, ihr habt Sand im Schuh. Die Elbe, die Elbe, oh, die Flut. Die Elbe tritt über, oh nein, die hat den Jonathan mitgerissen. Cocktail-Erfrischung, bieb, bieb, bieb. Der Rhein tritt über das Ufer, oh nein, die Johanna, oh nein, jetzt wird sie mitgerissen. Es fängt an zu regnen, das Monopoly ist doch noch aufgebaut. Johanna war eh die Unbeliebteste. Wir können weiter feiern. Oh shit, Hannah war doch auch der Name der Freundin von einem Hörer, die ihn verlassen hat. Jetzt wurde Hannah im Rhein mitgerissen. Schade. Wir hören nicht so lange auf zu Podcasten, bis alle fucking Hannas dieses Landes Single sind. Jede fucking Hannah kegeln wir aus ihrer Beziehung. Was der ist, was er wolle. Hannas sterben einsam und das werden wir durchziehen, wenn auch nichts anderes. Falls ihr euch fragt, was sind das für abgefahrene Stimmen, die hier aus meinem Samsung Galaxy gerade herauskriegten, blubbern, dann sage ich euch, wer das ist, Freunde. Das ist Stefan Tietze. Und Florantin Will. Und wir sind das Podcast-Ofo. Zusammen sind wir das Podcast-Ofo. Wir nehmen heute auf an diesem wunderschönen, herrlichen Feiertag. Es ist draußen, oh, die Sonne strahlt. Die Frauen zeigen wieder Knöchel. Endlich, ich liebe Knöchel. Machen dich Knöchel auch so wahnsinnig geil. Richtig, ich werde so rallig, wenn ich den Knöchel sehe. Ich könnte diesen Knöchel, ich könnte ihn einfach an. Diese dünne Haut und dieses harte Knöchel. Und dann dieser kleine Ball, diese Tennisball-grosse Knöchel. Ja, ja, ui, ui, ui. Bist du eher Tennisball, Tennisball oder Team Mandel? Nee, Team Mandel, auf jeden Fall Mandel und vor allem auch Gelenk. Wenn sich das so richtig weit biegen lässt, so über 180 Grad. So ein bisschen knackt dann. Aber Knöchel. Richtig cool. Und Brüste, aber mehr Knöchel. Ersch ist auch cool. Nee, aber ansonsten, ich habe heute meine kurze Hose rausgeholt. Und ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor dem, ich nenne ihn immer den Ground Zero des Sommers. Und das ist der Moment, in dem man seine kurze Hose wieder auszieht von der lange Hose. Man merkt, man war zu früh. Man merkt, man war einfach zu früh.
Das ist mir schon zweimal passiert.
Man hat versucht, im Sommer zu forcieren.
Du kannst im Sommer nicht forcieren.
Doch, du kannst im Sommer forcieren.
Nee, kannst du nicht.
Du kannst aber einfach, also mein Tipp an alle da draußen,
ab 21 Grad kurze Hose.
Schön ins Handy gucken, was sagt iPhone, was sagt Samsung Galaxy,
wie warm es heute wird.
Maximal Temperatur über 21, gleich kurze Hose. Was ist eigentlich das mit gefühlter Temperatur? Ich frage mich immer, ist es nicht total unwissenschaftlich, sozusagen so, ja, es ist 20 Grad, aber ich fühle 8 Grad. Ja, es interessiert mich nicht. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sehr schlecht Temperaturen einschätzen können. Herr Kasselmann, was du fühlst, deine subjektive Meinung. Es regnet zwar, aber mir zu Hause dann nicht. Vor allem bringt die Temperatur auch ein bisschen von der Gefühlslage an. Also ich finde, es ist cooler, wenn da drunter steht, so etwas wie gefühlte Temperatur, wenn sie glücklich sind, 21 Grad, wenn sie traurig sind, 12 Grad. Heute ist Winteranfang, aber wenn sie verliebt sind, dann ist immer Sommer. Das interessiert mich nicht. Das interessiert mich nicht. Das finde ich schlecht. So ein sehr emotionaler Wetterbericht. Wissen Sie, für Sie ist immer Sonne, wenn Sie glücklich sind. Sie können bei sich auch zu Hause drinnen Sonne haben, wenn Sie wollen. Bei nichts anderem. Du kannst nicht in der Matheklausur schreiben, das Ergebnis ist 14, aber die gefühlte Antwort ist 8. Ja genau,. Was soll das heißen? Meteorologie ist die einzige etwas
vage Wissenschaft. Subjektive Wissenschaft.
Ist auch für mich auf einer Ebene wie diese Horoskop-Scheisse.
Bullshit. So genau, morgen ist Tag
des Löwen, okay, morgen regnet's.
Hast du jemals
aktiv nach dem Wetterbericht deine Sachen
gepackt oder sowas? Noch nie, noch nie, und ich lache jeden aus,
der das tut. Ich lache jeden, lache ich ins
Gesicht, der sagt, oh, für morgen
liege ich mir mein Ringenschirm parat. Ja, vor allem aber, also warum braucht man das einen Tag vorher, diese Info? Also wenn man nicht gerade den Beruf hat wie Pilot oder so. Braucht man diese Info, auch da braucht man die Info nicht. Du brauchst einfach, du musst ab dem Moment, wo du die Entscheidung treffen musst, was ziehe ich an, da muss die Temperatur wissen und da kannst du in dein Handy gucken und die ist sehr genau. Wetter ist halt so wie Aktien so, es gibt immer wahnsinnig viele Prognosen und hoch und runter, aber es guckt niemand zurück, so wie oft waren diese Prognosen denn überhaupt richtig. Ich glaube, da gucken sehr viele zurück. Seit Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnung, dieser Satz, der sehr häufig zu hören ist, ist, glaube ich, das exakte Gegenteil von dem, was du bei dir gesagt hast. Okay, wir wissen jetzt gerade, was am 7. Dezember 1824 Wetter war. Schauen wir doch mal in die Tagesschau vom 7. Dezember 1824, ob da das richtig gesagt wird. Da ist schon wieder der handfesteste Streit, der zwischen uns immer ausbricht. Wenn du falsch liegst, wer ist das denn? Ständig musst du streiten. Oh, hallo, ist das Katjana? Warum fällt Katjana hier rum an einem Feiertag? Das finde ich ja immer spannend. Wer ist hier am Feiertag und warum? Oh nein, ich glaube, sie weiß nicht, dass heute Feiertag ist. Sie kommt dreieinhalb Stunden zu spät. Aber es ist Freitag. Das kann wirklich sein. Wir sind hier wieder in unserem Raum.
Wir sind in unserem Originalraum. Wir haben wieder den Blick auf den Hof.
Hof ist echt die schlechteste Entscheidung aller Zeiten.
Es ist ja so viele Momente,
vor allem letztens, es ist ja tatsächlich so,
dass sich bei uns auch in der Firma
jetzt so Sommergruppen bilden, die so
nach dem Feierabend so Feierabendbierchen
und Tischtennisblatt rausholen.
Oh, das war neulich so, obwohl du schon weg warst.
Wir haben einen ganz langen Aufzeichnungstag auf dem Aufzeichnungstag gehabt, wo du nicht da warst. Und da könnt ihr euch auch was freuen, Leute, da kommt was Tolles. Da haben wir ganz lange aufgezeichnet und abends wurde dann plötzlich gegrillt und dann war da plötzlich eine Tischtennisplatte und dann habe ich mit meinen Kollegen Rundlauf gespielt. Und ich verstehe nicht, wie bei den anderen dieser Ehrgeiz fehlen kann. Also natürlich mache ich den hohen Ball, damit der hinter mir sofort rausfliegt. Natürlich versuche ich, dass ich gegenüber unserer Praktikantin Lea stehe, dass ich sie sofort rausschießen kann, dass ich im Finale lande, um dann eine Krone zu bekommen. Damit sie nicht mag. Und dann gibt es diese geilen Begriffe. Dieses Um die, um die, um die Angabe, rufen immer alle Um die, Angauf und dann geht's wieder los. Ich stelle mir immer den einen indischen Tischtennisprofi vor, Umdi Ganani, der irgendwie massive Probleme auf Tischtennis zu tunieren hat, weil er nie genau weiß, was ist los. Umdi, was denn, bin ich jetzt dran oder was? Oder die Sprache, in der Umdi lauter Arschloch heißt. Umdi, ey! Aber ey, es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als mit Leuten spielen, die keinen Ehrgeiz haben. Immer wenn irgendwie Praktikantin Rebecca kommt und sagt, kann ich mitspielen? Und dann würde ich so, willst du gewinnen? Ja, willst du gewinnen. Willst du mehr gewinnen als deinen fucking Job behalten? Willst du gewinnen? Dein Blümchenshirt sagt, du willst nicht gewinnen. Richtig, du hast fucking hochhackige Schuhe an, du willst nicht gewinnen. Man sagt, nein, mir geht's um Spaß. Raus! Raus! Spaß, geh in deine scheiß gefühlte 14 Grad. Und dann wurde ich fertig gemacht, weil ich die ganzen Praktikantinnen rausgeschmissen habe die ganze Zeit. Und dann wurde ich fertig gemacht, haben alle alle auf Stefan jetzt. Es war so klar, dass Stefan wieder so spielt. So dann diese Sprüche kamen dann. Da denke ich mir, ist das ein Wettkampf oder was? Ist das ein Wettkampf oder was? Du hast eine Bierflasche in der Hand, du nimmst das offensichtlich nicht ernst. Mir geht's ja um den Spaß. Ja, aus dem Wettkham kommt doch grad der Spaß. Es macht doch kein gewinnendes Spaß. Ja, einen Ball in die Luft zu werfen, macht erst dann Spaß, wenn du einen Ring triffst, den du treffen willst. Du kannst einfach einen Ball... Und wenn du nicht in einem sehr engen Raum stehst, mit einer sehr tiefen Decke. Luftwerfen. Bullshit, ey, das ist echt immer nervig. Ey, wir müssen ganz kurz die Stimmung ein bisschen runterholen. Ich glaube, Herr Stratmann ist tot. Herr Stratmann ist ein Nachbar, der über mir wohnt. Oh nein. Und heute Morgen... Es tropft durch oder was, durch die Decke? Nein, heute Morgen kam plötzlich, waren Sirenen zu hören. Und dann kamen Rettungswagen. Oh nein. Und er stand dann vor uns und... Herr Stratmann ist jemand, der meine Pakete annimmt. Ist immer ein sehr aufgedrehter älterer Herr, der sehr lange zur Tür brauche, aber sehr aufgeregt dabei ist.
Also sein Körper sagt, ich bin in zwei Sekunden an der Tür, seine, die tatsächliche Uhrzeit sagt, er hat zehn Minuten gebraucht, um mir das Paket, mein Zalando Paket zu geben.
Sehr netter Kerl, aber er trägt so ein bisschen auch schon so das Stichwort Tod auf der Stirn, so ein bisschen vor sich mit.
Und ich glaube, der Krankenwagen war sehr lange da und am Ende ist er sehr langsam wieder weggefahren. Ohne Blaulicht. Ohne Blaulicht. Und deswegen wollte ich ganz kurz sagen, ich würde ganz kurz gerne eine Schweigeminute für einen Stratmann arbeiten, okay? Kann man auch im Schnitt länger machen, oder? Kann man im Schnitt länger machen, müssen sich wirklich nicht. Aber was ist in deiner Wohnung los, ey? Erst Jeff, jetzt Herr Stratmann, du wohnst gegenüber von der, was, der Paläontologie? Ja, das war neulich auch. Was der Hölle ist in deiner Wohnung los? Ich bin neulich auf den Flur gelaufen, die Wohnungseingang gelaufen und dann ruchst du nach Fisch und denkt man ja erst so, wow, geil! Wenn dann eine Familie rausgeht und dann sagt man, oh, Rita, Fischgul, die Nachbarn machen irgendwie schön Fisch oder so, aber ich wohne neben der Paläopathologie. Pathologie. Paläopathologie, die holen den Archäoptrix nochmal raus. Nämlich, wir wohnen neben der Pathologie und da ist der Fischgeruch etwas Furchtbares, wo man dann auch so den Sohn nimmt, wenn man in Familie wäre und sagt, komm, raus, raus, Luft einhalten und raus, renn, guck nicht nach hinten. Aber was heißt Fischgeruch, eine Wasserleiche oder eine tote Frau? Ich glaube Wasserleiche, es roch so nach Sumpfleiche. Es roch nach Sumpfleiche. Ja, so nach Sumpf, weißt du, diese gut konserviert, aber schon ein bisschen gammelnd. Es war wirklich furchtbar. Und dann roch oft auch Foodora-Fahrer, die dann fragen, warum riecht es ja eigentlich so nach Krankenhaus und so. Und ich merke dann, merkt man einfach, wie man abstumpft, dass man das gar nicht mehr wahrnimmt. Ey, vor allem, ich glaube, Foodora sind einfach die abgestumpftesten Menschen der Welt, die haben schon alles gesehen. Und wenn sie sich erkundigen, wo zur Hölle bin ich hier gerade? Ich meine, die liefern regelmäßig an irgendwelche Friedhöfe oder an irgendwelche Leute, die in einem Leuchtturm sitzen. Dann glaube ich, sagen die auch einfach so, wo bin ich hier, bin ich hier noch sicher? Oh nein, nicht wie der Leuchtturm, ich wohne in Köln, ich muss aber als Foodora-Fahrer immer die Nordsee fahren. Oh nein. Gibt es jetzt nicht auch so diesen Lieferservice, der an das Bett liefert, wo man irgendwie den Wohnungsschlüssel hinterlegen kann und dann muss man nicht mal aufstehen, sondern die füttern dich auch? Das finde ich gut. Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Ich glaube, irgendwann, wenn man diesen Stahl ist, einfach so im Bett zu liegen und nicht mehr zu machen, dann hat man es, glaube ich, geschafft. Alter, weißt du, was, was ich, ey, unglaublich, weißt du, was ich letztens in Hamburg gesehen habe? Ich laufe durch Hamburg mit meiner coolen Rocket Beans Gang, wir waren auf dem Weg zum Burgerladen, und dann kommt uns entgegen ein fucking Roboter. So ein weiss, also so eine untere Hälfte weiss, obere Hälfte schwarz, so ein Kasten, ungefähr wie so ein Kinderwagen, nur ein bisschen tiefer gelegt, mit vier Rollen, fährt selbstständig durch die Straße. Oh! Und ich so, sorry, werden wir gerade angegriffen, übernehmen jetzt die Roboter und so. Und dann die völlig gelangweilt so, nö, das ist jetzt der automatische Paketservice. Die fahren das Paket zu dir. Und ich denke mir, bitte, was?
Es gibt ein, wie mein Blowing ist das denn? Was? Und ich habe die ganze Zeit umgeguckt, da muss doch jemand in der Nähe sein, der das fernsteuert. Nein, das Ding fährt selbstständig und da war tatsächlich, die obere schwarze Hälfte war so halb opak, da konnte man so durchgucken. und da war ein Paket drin, braunes fucking Amazon-Paket.
Und der fährt zu dir und dann kriegst du irgendwie eine Message
und dann machst du die Tür auf und dann holst du das aus dem Roboter raus. Ihr Roboter wurde überfahren. Ja. Aber vor allem, ich verstehe das nicht. Es gibt offensichtlich eine Zweiklassengesellschaft bei Robotern. Klar, also die einen Roboter, das sind diese Rasenmäher-Roboter, die es nicht gebacken bekommen, auf dem Rasen zu bleiben. Und dann sieht man sich aus dem Steinweg langfahren. Man denkt so, fuck you. Not everybody who wonders is lost. Dann gibt es diese Roboter-Fails, wo man so eine Babyflasche hat, die das Kind einfach schlägt, massiv das Kind wegfliegt. Und dann gibt es diese Roboter, die Fußballroboter, die es nicht hinkriegen, Fussball zu schießen. Die Müllroboter, die die ganzen Mülltonnen über die ganze Straße verteilen. Und dann gibt es diese magischen Roboter, die wirklich funktionieren, offensichtlich, weil die eingesetzt werden. Oder auch Tesla, dieser automatische Drive. Vor allem meine erste Reaktion war, wer hindert mich denn jetzt daran, diesen Roboter einfach umzuschmeißen, auf den Rücken zu schmeißen. Dass der hilflos auf den Rücken hängt. Die drei AK-47, die in dem Roboter versieden waren vielleicht. Aber meine erste, tatsächlich meine instinktive Reaktion war, das muss ich aufhalten. Ich muss aufhalten, dass Roboter jetzt die Jobs von Menschen übernehmen. Das war eine, ich glaube, urmenschliche, instinkthafte Reaktion, das geht zu weit. Ich will den aufhalten, ich will den kaputt machen. Und ich meine, es ist ja einfach für die Konkurrenz von diesem Anbieter, der läuft einfach die Stadt und wirft die um auf den Rücken. Oder da macht so einen grossen Magnet drauf. Ja, oder macht die Reifen, und da musst du halt immer irgendeinen Trottel organisieren. Die Reifen kaputt war jetzt eine Idee. Aber warum nicht bei dem, also warum kann die DPD-Leute können ja auch einfach von den DHL-Leuten die Reifen kaputt stechen? Naja gut, aber da ist es Mensch gegen Mensch, da hat man ein gewisses Mitgefühl. Aber Mensch gegen Maschine, da sagst du einfach ja fuck you einfach so. Ja, keine Ahnung, der Typ, gerade DHL-Mitarbeiter wissen genau, wie beschissen es ist, wenn du dann irgendwie deine Tour nicht schaffst, weil du deine Apparaturen nicht aufhörst. Aber das sind doch auch wie so Mars-Rober. Roboter? Das sind doch auch wie so Mars-Rober, gibt es dann noch so eine Mission Control, die dann so ein Headset drauf haben mit so einer Zigarette im Mund und denen sie steuern und gucken, was da so passiert. Kann sein. Wir haben einen C-17 in Hektar 12ölf. Was ist das? Summaran, Summaran, was ist das? Nein, D-A-L! So läuft das doch. Ja, es wird doch bestimmt, ich meine, es gibt ja auch jetzt so Netzkanonen, wo man so Drohnen aus der Luft abschießen kann und so. Was wird es doch hundertprozentig geben, so Konkurrenz. Und irgendwann ist unsere fucking Innenstadt ein riesiges Schlachtfeld, wo Horden von Robotern so gegenseitig, wie so bei Quidditch, wo du dann so diese Dotzer oder diese Schläger hast, der ein einziger Job ist, die anderen Spieler einfach kampfunfähig zu machen. Ich habe kurz überlegt, was du meinst, du meinst durch den Ball, Quaffel. Ja, aber dann gibt es ja auch noch die, die, die... Weißt du mal die wieder? Quaffel und... Ey, wir müssen fucking Folge 103 ist Antenne Askar-Bahn, du musst die noch ein bisschen vorbereiten. Stimmt, wir machen die alle. Wir machen Antenne Apu, Antenne Askar-, Antenne Alcatraz und Antenne Allabastien. Und Antenne Inspector Gadget. Das ist ein bisschen, vergesst Inspector Gadget, wir haben uns nicht so vorbereitet. Aber es ist echt krass, also ich glaube, das wird noch sehr interessant und irgendwann kommen da Gesetze, die da irgendwas regeln, weil das wird, glaube ich, wirklich Armageddon in den Strassen. Aber du hast ein bisschen recht, hast du ja schon. Warum hält man den nicht auf? Aber das wäre eine Sachbeschädigung, ich stimme an, dass das Video erwacht. Ja, aber von wem denn? Ja, gut. Ja, von wem wäre eine Sachbeschädigung, wenn du einfach so ein DAL-Boot umschlägst? Ja, und meinst du, all das Erste, dann kommt da so ein Zettel und sagt mal, äh, hallo, sorry, kann es sein, dass sie unseren Roboter auf den Rücken geworfen haben, sie voll honk? Dann legt er sich so auf dem Rücken und die Reifen drehen so durch. Nein, muss das Paket ausliefern. Ja, Lars, mein Mitbewohner in Hamburg, hat ja jetzt so einen Saugroboter, so einen Staubsaugerroboter, und der ist tatsächlich immer so, das ist wie so ein Kind, der hat ihn so programmiert, dass er immer um 16 Uhr seine Tour beginnt. Und halt, der fährt random durch die Wohnung, und wenn er es nach einer gewissen Zeit wieder im Umkreis von einem Meter zu seiner Dockingstation ist, dann parkt er da wieder.
Es kann aber sein,
wie er direkt dahin fährt, ausversichtlich.
Der fährt nicht irgendwann bewusst
zurück zu seiner Dockingstation, sondern er fährt einfach
willkürlich und irgendwann, früher oder später, wird er ankommen.
Kann aber auch sein, dass er dort nie ankommt. Also nie
natürlich nicht, aber es ist sehr lange gedauert.
Und er kommt halt immer nach Hause und muss dann wie so nach
einem Kind suchen, so wo ist er? Oder liegt
er irgendwie so irgendwie im Waschbecken? Oder hat versucht, auszubrechen. Oder hat versucht, was im Kühlschrank zu essen. Und hat irgendwie so Drogen genommen. Oder hat irgendwie so einen zweiten Roboter eingeladen und so, oh sorry, was, bist du schon wieder zu Hause? Ich stelle mir vor, wer einfach so auf dem Rücken liegt, so in der Mitte der Wohnung und man denkt so, was ist passiert? Was ist hier vorgefallen? Was war hier los? Ich finde das so ganz niedlich. Es ist ja auch so eine Studie, dass die meisten Leute geben ihren Staubsaugerobotern und Rasenmäherrobotern Namen. Und dann habe ich mal ein paar Leute im Freundeskreis gefragt und eine Studie durchgeführt. Tatsächlich haben die alle Namen. Mona, Moni, viel mit Mona. Und ich frage mich auch, warum, also warum gibt man den Namen? Es gibt diesen, wie heißt der nochmal, Touring-Test, wo man versucht, die Roboter möglichst menschlich da wirken zu lassen. Und da gibt es diese AIs, die man versucht, möglichst menschlich wirken zu lassen. Da wird Menschen immer denken, die schreiben mit Menschen in so Hilfe-Zentralen, Service-Zentralen Hotlines. Und tatsächlich, glaube ich, ist gar nicht so viel nötig, dass Menschen einfach direkt jemanden personifizieren. Es reichen vier Räder und eine random Fahrt durch die Wohnung. Ich glaube, so ein bisschen Eigenständigkeit und schon denkt man, geil. Da gab es ja auch mal lange das Gerücht, dass die CIA so eine künstliche Intelligenz entwickelt hat, die sie als Fake-Account in World of Warcraft eingesetzt haben, um zu testen, ob Spielern das auffällt, wenn sie mit einer künstlichen Intelligenz kommunizieren. Und das ist auch so, wo ich mir dachte, okay, wo ich irgendwie Rückblick in meine gesamten World of Warcraft Beziehungen nochmal in Frage gestellt habe. Ich meine, ich hatte mit Coco, unserem Mainhealer, hatte ich eine gute Beziehung, wir haben geheiratet in Stormwind. War das nur ein fucking CIA-Agent, war das eine künstliche Intelligenz? Ich meine, es ist schon erbärmlich. Es denke ich mir auch im echten Leben. Wenn ich kennengelernt habe, der so ein Roboterauge aus dem Kopf fällt, ist es wirklich ein Mensch oder hat man die mir hingestellt? Also angenommen, du arbeitest bei der CIA und du programmierst diese künstliche Intelligenz. Kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen. Was ist denn die bestmögliche Antwort, die deine AI gibt, auf die Frage Bist du eine künstliche Intelligenz? Nein, ja, was? Hä? Sorry, muss auf essen. Mama ruft. Kurz AFK. Aber im Ernst, was ist die überzeugendste Antwort darauf? Was sollte eine optimale Künstliche? Ich glaube, eine ironische Antwort sind. Ja, natürlich. Wahrscheinlich haben mich die Leute, wahrscheinlich die einfach die Wahrheit. Ja. Mich haben Leute bei der CIA im Pentagon. So ein Gag, ich muss mal meinen Programmierer fragen. Einen Moment, 1-0-1-0-0, Glitz, oh, hupsala.
Nee, ich bin wirklich ein Roboter.
Dieser Spieler ist verdammt lustig.
Ist er wirklich so lustig?
Ich glaube, das ist...
Humor verrät letztendlich.
Ja, ich glaube, die lustigsten Leute sind meistens nicht echt.
Comedy-Bot.
Letztens habe ich so ein Video gesehen von irgendeiner
Künstlichen Intelligenz, die so Barockmusik komponiert hat.
Und die ist ja eigentlich im Grunde recht simpel.
Wie unser Weihnachtssong.
Ja, weil ich meine, Barockmusik ist ja abgeschlossen, die wird ja nicht mehr geschrieben.
Das heißt, du gibst dir einfach sämtliche Stücke, die es gibt, ein und dann ist es ja einfach ein mathematischer Algorithmus.
Finde Muster, finde Übereinstimmungen und generiere neue Muster.
Warum ist es dafür wichtig, dass es schon abgeschlossen ist? Weil, ich meine, du kannst auch alle Popmusik-Sachen reinspeisen und dann macht er daraus einen Popsong. Ja, Popmusik verändert sich ja ständig. Dann macht er einen Popsong und du denkst, das ist ja lame. Ja, der ist in zehn Jahren dann lame. Aktuell ist er ziemlich geil, wahrscheinlich. Ja, weiß er nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht. Und dann wo fängt Pop an und wo hat Pop auf? Ja, das hast du bei Bob auch die Frage. Was ist der erste P erste pop song man sagt ja die am on the highway the hell ist das ist pop aber es ist wirklich musiktheoretische frage was ist der erste pop song ich glaube es ist ein beatles song ich glaube weil die sind gelten als die erfinder des pop weil die des Pop. Weil die angefangen haben, Rock ... Elvis, Elvis davor? Nee, das war Rock'n'Roll. Ja, King of Pop, wie man da auch sagt. Michael Jackson. Ja, aber der ist der King of Pop. Davon muss es ja schon Leute geben, die Hofnachen des Pop, die immer so in den Wirken ähnlichen haben. Der Pharao des Pop. Weißt du was? Warum will ich der fucking Pharao des Pop?
Warum will ich nicht der König des Pop sein? Wir können das mal googeln. Kaiser. Übrigens, es hieß Klatscher. Ach ja, Klatscher. Quaffel, Klatscher, Schnatz. Hast du gerade die Community offen oder was? Sind wir gerade live eigentlich? Potter Vicky habe ich gerade offen. Popmusik. Der erste Popsong der Welt ist ... äh ... gut, ähm ... Lass mich raten, du schneidest es am Ende so, dass es so wirkt, als hättest du es gewusst und nicht gegoogelt. Der. Oh, okay, cool. Vielen Dank, Internet. Ich habe mich vergoogelt. Danke, Internet. Das wäre auch ein lustiger Sketch, wenn das Internet eine Person wäre, der immer so komplett sinnlose Antworten gibt und dafür auch immer noch sehr lange braucht. Mega gut. Das weiss ich. Manchmal das Gefühl, du redest nur, um das gut schneiden zu können danach. Einfach so dieses, du wartest dann drei Sekunden und dann. Ja stimmt, aber nächstes Thema. Man kann gar nicht mehr normal mit dir reden. Knöchel zeigen, genau. Ein anderes lustiges Thema, was mir auch gefallen ist. Ne, also, ich habe akute Geldprobleme. Ich muss kurz darüber reden. Ja, es ist tatsächlich. Man merkt es dir auch an, aber fuck Gott. Ja, ein bisschen. Also, es ist ein bisschen so, ich war in Orlando, jetzt buchen wir, haben wir für New York gebucht. Wir sind wieder eine Woche lang in New York. Gute Arbeit durch New York. Dann Humorkongress, Orlando, diese ganzen Fehlkäufe, die betreiben mich gerade in Ruinen. Ich studiere nicht mehr, ich muss Semesterticket bezahlen, ich habe mich jetzt im Fitnessstudio angemeldet. Es geht so viel ab, mein Gehalt wurde massiv gekürzt, weil aufgefallen ist, dass ich von der Kaffeemaschine die Tabs klaue. Und deswegen bin ich jetzt zu viel in dem Ruinen. und ich habe eine tolle App entdeckt, die, als wäre es geplant gewesen, als wäre das lebende Matrix, hat hier herausgefunden, was mein Problem ist gerade, was ein potenzieller Lösungsansatz ist und mir die Lösung hingeschickt. Mein Auto, ist auch sehr teuer, steht aber fünf Tage die Woche lang rum. Dann meistens war ich am Wochenende irgendwie damit rum. Aber fünf Tage die Woche steht es alleine da. Und es gibt jetzt eine App, die ganz neu am Markt ist, wo man sein Auto vermieten kann. Du kannst dein Auto die Tage, an denen es nicht gebraucht wird, vermieten an Leute, die es in den Tagen brauchen. Für, sagen wir mal so 30 Euro kannst du dann pro Tag dein Auto vermieten. Und du musst dafür nichts tun, außer dich dein Auto eingeben und den Schlüssel morgens weggeben. So, wie viele Podcast-Ufo-Hörer versuchen jetzt, diese App zu benutzen, um genau das Auto von Stefan Thiel zu bekommen, Ihr könnt gerne mein Auto haben. um dann da irgendwie so geheime Botschaften reinzuschreiben oder es absichtlich gegen die Wand zu fahren. Ihr könnt gerne meinen, ja, guter Tipp, danke, dass du das ansprichst. Es ist versichert sogar für die Zeit, das heißt, die können machen, was sie wollen damit. Aber wie funktioniert das? Die können es auch von der Brücke schmeißen. Wo ist der Schlüssel? Woher kriegen die Leute den Schlüssel? Ich muss dann auf die Solle warten und den Schlüssel geben. Persönlich, die klingeln bei dir. Ja, die klingeln bei mir. Okay, ja, dann kannst du dich auf eine Menge Podcast-Uvo-Hörer gefasst machen, die deinen fucking Auto... Ich bin nicht mit meinem Namen da drin. Eines Thema. Aber das sind jetzt diese aktiven Schritte, die ich mich langsam. Bald bin ich auch Uber-Fahrer und Fahrradkurier, bald habe ich auch so ein Bluetooth-Headset am Kopf, wo ich die ganze Zeit nebenbei mit anderen Gesprächen beschäftigt bin. So Micropayment-Sachen, du tippst immer so Gutscheincodes ab irgendwo. Einfach den ganzen Tag on edge. Und in der Spilo, vor allem in der Spilo, die ganze Zeit. Goldgrube Spilo. Aber ganz kurz einfach nochmal um diese Storyline auch endlich, die die Leute ja schon lange irgendwie auf dem Zahnfleisch kauen lassen. Wie geht es denn dein Boosted Board? So, das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich ansprechen, deswegen das ganze Thema. Ich muss es abstellen. Guck mal, und an alle Leute da draußen, die einerseits sagen, ah, die Boosted Board Storyline ist meineblings-Storyline, andererseits, ich will aber nichts bei PayPal spenden und ich will nichts bei Patreon spenden. Das habt ihr jetzt davon. Nein. So funktioniert es nicht. Ihr habt mir verboten, an die Patreon-Einnahmen zu gehen. Ich darf nicht an die Spenden gehen. Ihr könnt jetzt nicht einerseits sagen, ich würde gerne Stefan auf seinem Boosted-Bot durch Ehrenfeld Düsen sehen, andererseits, ich will nichts bei Patreon spenden. Stefan ist in ernster Geldsorge und deswegen rufen wir noch mal an. Jetzt instrumentellisierst du mich jetzt dafür, dass wir mehr Geld bekommen. Ein Geld, was mir nicht hilft. Du kannst dir einen Kredit holen, du kannst dir einen Patreon, der Podcast-UFO-Kredit. Das ist das Armseligste, das ist wirklich Rockbottom, habe ich jetzt erreicht. Finanzielles Rockbottom, Kredit beim Podcast. Wir sind bald auch eine Bank, wir verleihen so Geld, wir geben Startups und Ruck nach vorn. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Nicht so schlecht. Wollen wir alles auf Rot setzen, einmal? Einmal so alles auf Rot? Boah, das fände ich nicht schlecht. Es wäre ein Fingerzeig, ein Mittelfingerzeig in Richtung Community. Auf jeden Fall. Aber das ist spannend, ey. Wir machen ja irgendwann die Folge aus Los Angeles, ich sag mal Folge 146 und dann, nee, Las Vegas, und dann setzen wir alles auf Rot. Casino Hochburg, Los Angeles. Nee, aber die Community darf abstimmen, ob wir auf schwarze oder rot setzen. Das finde ich so gut. Und dann ist es ihre Schuld, wenn sie verliert. Oder auf die Zahl 12. Alles auf Zahl 12, aber das ist nämlich so Multimillionärer. Aber aus Versehen. Und die Comedy so, ey, es war unser. Sorry, sorry. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Wir machen mal eine Twitter-Umfrage, Rot oder Schwarz. Jetzt, glaube ich, ziehen alle ihre Patreon-Spenden zurück, weil sie alle wissen, dass wir einfach das ganze Geld verzocken einfach. Aber ihr wusstet, ihr habt doch vorher geahnt, dass das Ende sein wird. Natürlich. Erst mal verlieren wir das Passwort, dann ist alles weg. Ich sehe so, ab Folge 103 sitzen wir so betrunken beim Podcast und reden so betrunken Halbwissen irgendwie. So, wir meinen irgendwie, ja, wir können jetzt Karten zählen und sowas. Wir sind mitten in so einem Spiel so drin. Das komplette Projekt driftet ab, völlig ruiniert. Ja. Ach, Stefan, aber du schläfst jetzt wirklich hier, oder was? Ja, ich schlafe jetzt. Weil du hast deinen Schlafsack dabei. Ich habe meinen Schlafsack mit und meine Luftmantratze. Und hier ist eine Couch in diesem Raum. Die ist halb so groß wie du, da musst du dich einrollen, wie so eine Katze. Das ist sehr klein, ja, in Biominalstellung, klein und sehr hart. Ich wohne jetzt hier, also natürlich auf dem Hof, wenn es abends nicht regnet oder so und nicht zu kalt wird, kann man ja auch rausgehen. Nein, mir geht es gut. Also eigentlich geht es mir ganz gut. Ich muss nur finanziell ein bisschen Vorkehrungen treffen. Wie darfst du Training? Gestern habe ich meinen Personal Trainer, danke nochmal an Cedric, der mich gestern durch das Fitnessstudio geführt hat. Ich hatte mein erstes Personal Training und es war wirklich toll. Also ganz toll, viele Sachen. Also der hat mich erst mal gefragt, was ich so will. Dann hat er mich an die End gesagt. Was willst du denn? Ich habe gesagt, vor allem gut aussehen, nackt, sehr gut aussehen, bei meinem Zitat. Und dann hat er mich gesagt, dann haben wir ein bisschen so redet. Das hast du mir nicht gesagt. Nein, er hat gesagt, ja, ein bisschen in Form kommen. Ja, wie meinen Sie, in Form kommen? Ja, so in Shape kommen. Dann habe ich mich in verschiedenen Sprachen durch meine Aufmerzen, um das Synonym.
In Forma.
Und dann war viel Gelächter, viel Fragezeichen in seinem Gesicht.
Und dann, mein Fettanteil im Körper sind 16 Prozent. Und das meinte er, wäre ziemlich gut.
Ich dachte, das wäre wesentlich mehr. 16 Prozent ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Mein körperliches Alter ist 17. What? Ist das auch nicht gut? Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist jetzt sehr jung. Das ist schon präpubertär fast jung. Aber was soll das bedeuten, ein körperliches Alter? Was ist dein Alter als dein körperlich? Ja genau, ich dachte auch, das ist doch eine Lüge, ich lüge mich aber jetzt gerade selbst, weil ich bin offensichtlich 22, aber mein körperliches Alter wäre 17, ich wäre noch sehr fit, also für zwei- und zwanzigjährigen, ich bin, sagen wir mal, wenn ein 80-Jähriger sich fühlt wie ein 50-Jähriger, ist es so wie ein 22-Jähriger sich fühlt wie ein 17-Jähriger, ich bin einfach noch topfit, weißt du, ich habe noch keine Probleme mit den Gelenken, mir geht es einfach wie so ein richtig frisch gebackener 17-Jähriger.
Aber das ist auch eine dumme Frage, oder was wollen Sie denn, wenn man zum Fitnessstudio geht? Ja, was denkst du denn? Nee, manche wollen ja gesund. Ich will zum Mond fliegen können. Manche wollen, oh, oh, oh, du verdammtes Arschloch, will zu sein. Nee, es ist tatsächlich so, dass man manche einfach auch gesund sein wollen und so. Nee, ich will einfach gut ausnehmen. Das ist natürlich primär, da hast du da mir ein bisschen Ernährungstipps gegeben, Juhel, massiv von abgeraten. Und dann hat er mich angefangen, dann zu den ersten Geräten zu führen. Und dann, das erste Gerät war das, wovor ich am meisten Angst habe, es war nämlich Bankdrücken, wo man sich hinlegen muss, dann hat man diese typischen Muskelsachen, diese große Stange mit den Gewichten dran und man muss die hochnehmen. Und dann haben wir erstmal die Stange so ohne Gewicht genommen, damit er mir die Bewegung zeigt. Dann sollte ich mich hinlegen, habe dann die Stange genommen, ohne Gewicht, es ging gut und so, und dann sind wir gegangen. Dann hat er immer so aufgeschrieben, was für eine Übung ich nehmen soll, mit welchem Gewicht, und er hat das Gewicht nicht eingetragen. Dann habe ich gesagt, was soll ich denn da drauf machen, was stemme ich denn so, sagt man ja auch immer, Bankdrücken ist das auch immer, wenn man zu seinen Fitnesskumpels geht, dann fragen die immer, was stemmst du so, yo, ich muss nur die Stange hochdrücken. Das kam dann raus, ich soll keine Gewichte nehmen erstmal, die Stange reicht völlig aus. Und welche Wiederholungen? Eine. Zwölf, dreimal zwölf, dreimal eine. Es ist technisch nicht möglich, weniger Workouts zu machen. Nee, genau. Ich soll dreimal zwölf ohne Gewicht nehmen. Und das hat sich dann so ein bisschen durch die ganzen Geräte gezogen, dass ich am besten einfach zu Hause bleiben sollte wahrscheinlich. Aber tatsächlich meinte er, ich habe sehr viel Muskelmasse, die nicht aktiviert ist. Was soll das denn heißen? Ich habe 80 Prozent von dem, was er gesagt hat, nicht verstanden. Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Aber augenscheinlich habe ich noch von meinen Tennisjahren, wo ich in der Weltrangliste locker mal auf Platz 1.7 Millionen war, da habe ich jetzt wohl noch ein paar Restmuskeln, die eingeschlafen sind, die in Ruhezustand gefahren sind, zum Mondzustand, und die kann ich jetzt wieder aktivieren, indem ich einfach ein bisschen was trainiere. Was ganz gut ist. Ich habe nicht so viel Körperfett. Ich verstehe es auch gar nicht. Weil ich meine, entweder du hast Muskeln, aber nicht. Du kannst ja nicht, wenn du deinen Bizeps anspannst, sag doch nicht, ist die Hälfte des Bizeps, nur ich mache da jetzt nicht mit bei. Naja, ich will dem Fitnesstrainer jetzt nicht widersprechen. Nee, ich auch nicht, aber ich verstehe nicht, was es bedeutet.
Augenscheinlich gibt es Muskeln, die
nicht automatisch zurückbilden
sofort, sondern die einfach da bleiben,
aber die einschlagen. Die werden dann erst so auf Standby
und dann langsam abgebaut. Genau, augenscheinlich ja.
Ich finde es auch ganz strange, aber es klang alles
relativ cool. Ich dachte auch, ich werde wesentlich mehr Körperfett und so.
Aber ja, alles cool, jetzt trainiere ich
einfach jetzt. Bin ich einer von denen, die trainieren.
Ja, aber machst du es? Willst du es richtig? Ja, ich tue es zweimal die ziehe ich jetzt da hin und mache das. Auf jeden Fall so, die nächsten Wochen habe ich auf jeden Fall, ich habe gerade Motivation für die nächsten fünf Wochen, glaube ich. Oder fünf Wochen, ich sage viel. Und dann mal gucken, was dann passiert, aber es ist schon ganz cool. Ich bin gespannt. Ist auch ein gutes Fitnessstudio, da sind halt die, also Assis, die ein bisschen mehr, die nicht nur eine Beleidigung können, Also die können dich auch eloquent beleidigen, wenn du deren Gerät gerade einnimmst. Ja, das ist schon ganz cool. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich berichte davon. Cool, was machst du jetzt? Wir müssen nochmal Fit, das kann auch lustig jetzt machen. Ja, auf jeden Fall, klar, wir wollen ja Badminton spielen gehen. Ja, nächstes Mal. Ja, kann man. Ich bin mal gespannt, ey. Ich habe meine Badminschläge jetzt in Köln. Ich meine, deine Muskeln sind komplett eingeschlafen. Ich habe keine Muskeln, von daher ist es einfach, glaube ich, ein fehl ist. Not gegen Elend, fortwörtlich. Der schlafende Riese gegen den Zwerg. Also wer gewinnt? Das ist schwierig. Aber vielleicht hast du, ich meine, du hast dir erzählt aus deinen Kindergartenjahren, dass du einfach ein bisschen müde bist. Vielleicht hast du einfach müde Muskeln. Das kann wirklich nicht gut sein. Oh, ich lege mich hin. Muskeln, Doppelpunkt, zzz. Diesen Wert hatten wir noch nie. Ach wirklich, ich drehe mich noch mal um. Ich bin echt sehr müde, aber ist das normal? Bist du auch müde? Du schläfst auch viel, oder? Nee, ich schlafe nicht so viel. Warum? Also ich verstehe, Leute, ich muss ganz viel schlafen. So zehn Stunden, elf Stunden brauche ich Schlaf, sonst kommt mir nichts zu gebrauchen. Ja, bei mir ist es so, ich kann erstens nicht so wahnsinnig gut schlafen und zweitens will ich halt immer zu lange wach bleiben. Muss raus nachts auch oft, ne? Na, das manchmal. Aber ich rechne halt immer so, wann muss ich aufstehen, um acht Uhr dreissig und dann weiß ich, okay, dann gehe ich um null Uhr dreissig ins Bett, weil ich acht Stunden dann schlafe. Und dann ist es null Uhr dreissig und dann denke ich mir, naja, komm, jetzt ziehe ich mir noch ein Dota, spiele ich noch ein Spiel Dota, dann ist es 1.30 Uhr. Und dann so, ja, gut, jetzt noch zwei YouTube-Videos, dann ist es 2 Uhr. Dann okay, ich lese noch im Bett, dann ist es 2.30 Uhr. Und dann letztendlich schlafe ich, habe ich dann noch sechs Stunden, von denen ich dann vielleicht fünf Stunden tatsächlich schlafe. So ist es eigentlich immer, dass ich mir viel vornehme, aber dann schrumpft es immer mehr. Schlafen ist so strange, oder? Ja. Ich finde das ganz komisch. Das sind diese Dinge, die man machen muss einfach, die so anfallen. Und die kann man auch nicht verhindern. Was macht man denn genau? Man verarbeitet Dinge? Was verarbeitest du denn in deinen Träumen? Das ist eine weitreichende Frage. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe auch mal so eine Schlafdoku gesehen, wo es hieß, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt, aber ich habe es noch nicht verstanden, dass Wissenschaftler nicht genau wissen, warum man schläft. Und die einzige Begründung war, weil man müde ist. Also weil der Körper eine gewisse Müdigkeit erzeugt, aber was genau der Körper damit bezwecken will, kann man, also ich meine, jeder versteht, dass Schlaf notwendig ist und dass man sich schlecht fühlt, wenn man nicht schläft, aber warum jetzt das genau notwendig ist, weiss man nicht. Ich will in meinem Leben nur eines, und darauf arbeite ich hin, scheiß auf Karriere, scheiß auf alles andere. Ich will mich irgendwann, wenn zu nun auch einschläfern lassen oder einfrieren lassen, um den Moment mitzubekommen, wie wir auf andere Aliens stoßen, auf andere Aliens, auf Aliens stoßen, auf andere Rassen im Universum. Weil, stell dir mal vor, wir treffen auf eine Rasse, die nicht schläft. Und wie strange das für die sein muss, wenn wir plötzlich einfach alle plötzlich einfach, die reden mit uns und plötzlich schlafen wir ein und dann die, wow, was ist jetzt los? Es gibt ja bestimmt Arten, die nicht schlafen. Es gibt auch Tiere, die nicht alter. Regenwurmen? Ja. Also ich meine so einen ganz kleinen Bereich, so Bakterien werden nicht schlafen. Man träumt einen Regenwurm. Oh, Erde, Erde, Erde, Erde. Oh, Regen, Regen, Regen, Regen. Albtraum, Sonnenschein, Sonnenschein, trocken, trocken. Au, wenn Regen sich immer trocknen, dann ist das auch ganz ekelig. Mir tut das leid, dann. Mir tut es nicht so leid, weil die kein Gesicht haben, kein offensichtliches Gesicht.
Ich brauche bei Tieren immer so ein offensichtlich...
Ich auch, ja.
Zumindest Augen und Augenmund.
Ja, das stimmt.
Oder halt irgendwie so was Kopfähnliches, so wenn du weißt, Pflanzen tun dir Pflanzen manchmal leid?
Ja.
Welche denn?
Aber nur so, wo man denkt, wo man also so...
Fleischpresse, so diesen Gesicht...
Gänseblümchen, Gänseblümchen, die müssen zwei Blättern, die so arme sein können, und dieses Gesicht, wenn das so runder hängt, man denkt, oh, das tut mir schon manchmal ein bisschen leid. Pflanzen manchmal? Doch. Ja. Meinglöckchen. Narzissen. Ich habe früher alle Pflanzen zerstört. Ich bin wirklich mit dem Stock durch den Garten gelaufen, meine Mutter, tolle, grosse Blumenbeete, irgendwie Löwenzahn hier und da. Löwenzahn ist besonders gut, weil die haben ja so weisse Flüssigkeit drin, das dann Blut, und wenn du die halt so kaputt schlägst, dann spritzt da noch so weisses Blut weg, das fand ich total cool. Dann läufst du dich gegen und schlägst alles kaputt. Meine Mutter hat teilweise gesagt, hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Du hast alle Blumen fucking kaputt gemacht, einfach. Aber ich finde das einfach so toll, dann guckt man, dass man es versucht so zu schlagen, dass man es abtrennt, ohne dass es umknickt. Vor allem ist deine Mutter ja Grünpolitikerin, oder? Ja. Wie lustig das ist, wenn das irgendwie mal so einen Stadtfotograf mitbekommen hätte. Und dann wäre es zum anfesten Skandal in Ebersbach geworden. Vielleicht war das meine Form von Rebellion, dass ich einfach alle Pflanzen zerstört habe. Ja, vielleicht. Ja. So, Sie wollen Bürgermeisterin werden? Wir haben folgende Fotos von dem Sohn, wer alle Pflanzen zerstört, wie rechtfertigen Sie sich als grüne Politikerin? Ja. Du hast ihn doch mal in den Ruinen getrieben. Aber so ein ganzes Feld Löwenzahn und dann einmal mal durch so durchwämsender. Ich finde vor allem Pusteblume ist so eine gute Idee. Weil, also Pflanzen haben ja ein Ziel, sie wollen sich vorpflanzen irgendwie. Das ist das eigentliche Ziel. Ja, aber warum dann fucking Schale? Warum gibt es dann Schale? Wie? Also warum hat dann einen Granatapfel so eine Schale? Ich glaube damit... Ist nicht die Idee, dass die Tiere das fressen halt? So eine Kirsche verstehe ich. Kirsche check ich. Kirsche hängt am Baum, Rabe frisst die Kirsche und trägt dann den Kern irgendwo anders hin und dann wächst der neue Kirschbaum. Ja. Easy.uft. Warum haben so Nüsse und so Granatapfel, warum hat das so eine dumme Schale? Das ist bestimmte Tiere essen und das nicht, wenn es runterfällt, sofort verrottet. Vielleicht ist eine Kirsche auch eine Beere. Ach, ich hab überhaupt, ist mir auch scheiße. Ja, aber ich finde, Pustenblume sind so clever, weil du hast dieses modernes ist so ein modernes Marketing, einfach, dieses, wir sind jetzt, wir sind jetzt pustbar, so, wir sind jetzt so ein Spielzeug.
Scheren, du kannst sie scheren.
Einfach, man kann sie scheren.
Und dann hast du einfach, allein dieses, man will sie auch wegpusten.
Und wenn man es nicht wegpustet, dann hast du immer noch Wind, der es wegpustet.
Und dann verteilt sich das, und dann sind diese kleinen süßen Fallschirmen hier mit diesem Samen unten dran, finde ich klasse.
Super, ja, das ist ein moderner Marketing. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, was ist denn unsere, wie kriegen wir denn unser Podcast heraus? Was ist unsere Pusteblume? Unsere Marketing-Pusteblume. Das ist schwierig. Das Internet vielleicht. Ah, Pollen sind so scheiße. Pollen sind richtig scheiße. Hast du Probleme mit, hast du Allergien? Ganz merkwürdig. Ich bin ja, ich glaube, war ja Allergie gegen irgendwas. Ich habe ja diesen Allergietest gemacht, wo irgendwie so ein Arzt dann
so ein Schachbrettmuster mit so einem Kugelschreiber
auf deinen Armen malt und dann
irgendwie so Punkte und dann hast du irgendwie
so Diagonal oder so oder da steht dann irgendwie
so Bingo oder du musst dann irgendwie so Schiffe versenken
oder sowas. Und da hatte ich dann irgendwie so
irgendwie Buche, glaube ich, und
Hausstaub. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, was Buchen
sind, deswegen habe ich eigentlich vor jedem Baum Angst.
Ja, mein Arm war komplett rot danach, dass die gesagt haben, ach, bleib drin in der Wohnung einfach. Oder du bist allergisch gegen Coolschreiber. Und er war so stolz auf den Gag jetzt. Du warst so stolz auf den Gag gemacht. Da gibt es ja diese tolle Filmprämisse eines Charakters in Brothers Bloom, wie ein Mädchen Allergietest gemacht hat und der Rücken komplett rot war und sie dann einfach ihr Leben lang gezwungen, wo er war, im Haus zu bleiben und deshalb verschiedene Hobbys sich angeeignet hat, die in allen Hobbys gut ist, in so seltsamen Hobbys wie Jonglieren oder so plötzlich einfach mega gut ist, weil sie sich so viel Zeit alleine gebracht hat, so seltsame Dinge, so ganz viele Talente einfach perfekt beherrscht. Das finde ich cool. Schreib mal so einen Film. Ja, aber was ist dann das Ende? Nein, das ist nur ein Charakter von einem vielschichtigen Film, einem vielschichtigen... Achso, aber ich dachte, die Pointe ist, dass sie eigentlich allergisch war gegen den Allergitast. Nee, sie war im Endeffekt nicht allergisch, das war die Pointe. Ja, aber der Arzt war halt einfach... Nee, genau, weil sie sich vertan haben. Wow, das ist ein richtig cooler Film, wo die in den letzten fünf Minuten so, sorry, wir vertan. Credits. Das ist kein guter Film. Das war. Kein Film sollte mit dem Wort reden. Wir haben uns vertan. Wir haben uns vertan. Wir wollten gar nicht diesen Safe ausrauben. Vergess es. Warum haben die Aliens diesen Virus gestreut?
Ja, wir haben uns leider vertan.
Sorry! Ich finde es ja immer noch,
dieses abrupte Abbrechen finde ich ja so saulustig.
Ich muss da immer wieder dran denken,
auch von diesem Weihnachtsson, den wir gehört haben.
Lots and lots and lots and lots of flowers.
Und ich stelle mir auch immer so vor,
wie in so einem Kinofilm,
so der letzte Satz, und wir haben uns vertan. Zack, Licht an, alle Menschen stehen gleichzeitig auf und gehen raus. Einfach so wirklich, kein Credits, kein irgendwie am Ende nochmal rum, sondern wirklich sofort so, da-dam-dam-da-dam, zack, alle stehen auf und sind raus. So ein langsamer Film, der aber, so der letzte Satz wird nicht ausgesprochen, letzter Satz, der unterbricht es einfach. So als wäre die Zeit vorbei, nach genau 90 Minuten.
Der letzte Satz wird gerade gesagt, revealed und der Mörder war ...
Aber das finde ich mal einen coolen Prank.
Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen, so diese ...
Wie sagt man, diese Happenings, wo alle so gleichzeitig ...
Flashmobs.
So, und das fände ich einen coolen Flashmobs in so einem Kino, wo nur einer nicht eingeweiht ist und wenn der Film zu Ende ist, wirklich instant Licht an, alle stehen auf, Jacke an und sind sofort raus und der eine so what the fuck, was ist hier los? Das fände ich richtig lustig. Dafür würde ich das gesamte Patron-Geld ausgeben. Ich liebe das, aus dem Kino rauszugehen und Leuten zuzuhören, was sie dann sagen. Ja, dumm. Ja, aber ich finde das so beruhigend, dieses, ja, wie fand's es? Ich bin klüger als die. Wie fand's es? Ja, fand ich ganz gut. Habe ich nicht verstanden, diese eine Stelle. Ja, wie fand's es? Ja, immer gut. Eigentlich selten schlecht. Ja, selten schlecht, aber dann gibt es einfach noch so diese pretentious Vollidioten, die dann halt immer sofort so... Ein Akt drei. Die dann entweder sowas, halt so Strukturanalyse oder dann halt so direkt so so deuten so, ja, für mich war das floss eine Metapher für das und das und sowas, was ja an sich nicht schlecht ist, aber irgendwie in diesem das ist nicht das, was du wissen willst, wenn du das Kino verlässt und deine Jacke anziehst und sagst so, und wie fand's denn da willst du nicht hören, irgendwie so, ja, weißt du nicht, fand es jetzt irgendwie jetzt gerade im feministischen Aspekt interessant, dass irgendwie gerade der weibliche Aspekt dann so aufgeblüht im Blahwerber ist nicht... mit American Gods angefangen, eine Serie, neu auf Amazon. Ich bin gespannt, aber ich weiß nicht, wie man die angucken soll. Es ist vor allem... Also das Tolle, was ich da an der Serie mag, ist, dass ich keine Ahnung habe, worum es geht, nicht mal Ansatz checke, was los ist, und ich mich einfach reinwerfe. Ich und weiss, habe auch noch ähnlich viele Fragen. Aber tatsächlich habe ich mich
dann gefragt, das ist teilweise mit den
brutalsten Szenen, die ich jemals in einem Film gesehen
habe, aber halt übertrieben brutal,
so Tarantino brutal, mit spritzendem Blut
und Litern Blut, die durch die Luft spritzen und so.
Da denke ich mir, kann man noch viel brutaler
werden? Oder hat man, weil das ist ja auch einfach so,
das ist eine Mainstream-Serie, es ist ja nicht
irgendwie Splatter oder so gekennzeichnet.
Und kann man noch brutaler werden? Hat man da jetzt die Grenze erreicht? Ich finde es spannend, bei manchen Themen einfach über die Grenze nachzudenken. Ich glaube, auch bei Fernsehern, so bei der Schärfe, wie scharf Fernseher sein können, hat man irgendwann die Grenze erreicht. Ich glaube, irgendwann ist es fürs Auge schlicht nicht mehr wahrnehmbar, ob es schärfer ist oder nicht. Und ich glaube, bei dieser Serie ist es auch ungefähr einfach so der Brutalheitsgrad maximal erreicht.
Ich kann mir nichts vorstellen, was brutaler ist als das.
Das ist ja die Frage, wie du Brutalität definierst, ob das reine Körperlichkeit ist.
Glaube ich, dann ist es irgendwann ausgereizt.
Dann hast du halt irgendwann mal ein Auge zerschlitzt und irgendwie ein Gehirn explodiert. Ja, exakt.
Aber das ist halt dann irgendwie so absurd.
Aber tatsächlich hier irgendwie so Serbian Movie oder irgendwie solche Martyrs, wo das dann auch so psychologisch krass und total bedrückend und dann Folter-Szenen und lang und so, ohne halt so diesen psychologischen Aspekt, wo dann auch eine Brutalität herrscht. Aber es ist allein von körperlich. Genau, ich meine, ich meine rein körperlich, ich glaube, es ist einfach erzählt, das ist einfach alles gezeigt. Da kannst du auch keinen Tabus mehr brechen, so. Naja, aber vor allem das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht abschrecken, weil es ist ja dann irgendwo rein anatomisch irgendwie so, weil jeder weiß ja, wie ein Körper aussieht. Und wenn du einen Arm abschlägst, ich meine, furchtbar wird es ja eigentlich erst durch die, dadurch, dass du dich hineinversetzt, dass du jetzt denkst, ah, was würde, wenn es mir passiert und du irgendeine Verbindung aufbaust und du irgendwie denkst, okay, das muss ja schrecklich sein. Das hast du ja eigentlich du ja eigentlich gar nicht. Der Körper an sich ist ja neutral. Du musst ihn ja erst füllen mit Bedeutung und dann wird es erst schlimm, wenn du irgendwie zu der Figur was aufgebaut hast oder irgendwie damit dich reinfühlen kannst. Aber an sich der Körper, du kannst ja auch, ist da ein Bio-Unterricht brutal, wenn du so einen Frosch aufschneidest? Ja, das ist schon schlimmer. Habe ich auch viel reineinterpretiert in den Frosch.
Wo war der Frosch heute Morgen?
Hat der Frosch heute Morgen seiner Familie gesagt, tschüss, ich bin jetzt auf dem Weg zum Weiher und dann kam er nie wieder zurück.
Was war der brutalste Film, den du je gesehen hast, wo du wirklich so richtig einen flauen Magen hattest?
Ah, schwierig.
Ah, das ist, ich habe diese Netflix-Serie geguckt, 13 Reasons Why, die hatte am Ende bringt sich halt das Mädchen um und das weiss man, nein, das weiss man die ganze Zeit und das ist schon einfach sehr explizit dargestellt, also wirklich massiv explizit dafür, dass es die ganze Zeit so eine Highschool-Serie ist. Also in dem Kontext des Genres und der ganzen Serie ist das die brutalste Szene, die ich je gesehen habe. Aber sonst, weiss ich nicht, sonst schockt mich aber auch nicht so viel.
Also brutale Szenen, körperliche brutale Szenen. Ja. Also ich glaube, brutal wird es halt dann, wenn es dann auch irgendwie in Realismus geht. Also ich glaube, den schlimmsten Film, den ich in der Hinsicht gesehen habe, ist ein Dokufilm, The Act of Killing, heißt der, wo aber es halt basiert auf wahren Gegebenheiten und wo auch gar nicht viel gezeigt wird, sondern nur die Leute, die diese Tötungen gemacht haben, erzählen, wie das war und wie sie es erlebt haben. Und das ist grauenvoll, aber auch nicht explizit. Aber das ist eigentlich noch schlimmer, weil du nicht die Möglichkeit hast, dich durch dieses Spektakel irgendwie unterhalten zu lassen, sondern du hast allein das Kopfkino und du kannst dir einfach nur den ganzen Grauen vorstellen. Und auch wenn die das so neutral erzählen, wohingegen du ja noch so Spektakler hast, wenn du siehst, wie da irgendwie Leute den Kopf abgehackt bekommen, dann ist ja krass und ekel und traue ich mich da hinzugucken. Du hast dann viele Mechanismen, die das irgendwie vermitteln und nicht so unmittelbar sind. Das stimmt. Aber das stimmt, das ist ein krasser Film. Ja, jetzt haben wir die, du wolltest vor 20 Minuten die Stimmung runterziehen, jetzt hast du es geschafft. Yay! Wo gehst du noch hin? Du hast eine Isomatte dabei, also wirklich eine Ausstattung, mit der ich Stefan Titzel noch nie gesehen habe. Ich gehe heute Abend campen. Heute Abend campen? Nein, das ist nicht meine Isomatte da. Das ist auch nicht mein Schlafsack. Aber wie cool wäre das? Heute Abend schön campen, wir beide, schön an Weiher. Wie soll das, was meinst du mit campen? weißt du denn? Einfach ein Zelt aufschlagen. Für eine Nacht. Ja, schön Zelt aufschlagen, einfach mitten in der Stadt auch irgendwie, in so einem Park. Zelt aufschlagen, schön Grill aufstellen, schön die Brutzler auf den Grill schmeißen, für dich so ein veganes Blatt, schönes Blatt, Buchenblatt drauflegen und dann schön abends lesen wir uns Geschichten vor, Gruselgeschichten, mit einer Taschenlampe ins Gesicht, was ich massiv ungruselig finde, ist nicht Dunkelheit, naja, ist der Sinn, dass man, das habe ich nicht verstanden, ist der Sinn, dass man die Schatten wirft in seinem Gesicht und dass es eine Grimasse gibt oder so? Ich glaube, deine Augen sind dann schwarz, oder? Ja, weil die ja durch die Wangenknochen abgeschirmt werden und ich ich glaube, die leere, schwarze Augen sind gruselig.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, ich müsste jetzt ein Bild davon sehen, wie es aussieht.
Kann sein.
Aber hat mich jetzt auch nie umgehauen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe früher gerne diese Gänsehaut gelesen.
Ich fand das super geil.
Diese kleinen Bücher, diese Groschenromane von R.L. Stine, mega geil.
Nie gelesen.
Ich fand das so großartig.
Ich glaube, ich bin auch ein riesen Horrorfilm-Fan, du ja gar nicht.
Ich liebe das, ich finde das ganz toll.
Ich glaube, ich würde gerne mal sowas,
deswegen würde ich auch echt mal gerne irgendwie nach Amerika und einfach
so einen Roadtrip machen und dann einfach
übers Land fahren. Ich finde, das ist glaube ich,
da sind die Chancen auch echt gross,
dass du einfach straight umgebracht wirst.
Ich glaube auch. Gibt es gute
deutsche Horror, eine Horrorkultur
aus Deutschland? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, Deutschland ist so
dicht besiedelt, dass du immer das Gefühl
Vielen Dank. einfach straight umgebracht wird. Sehr umgebracht wird es, ja. Ich glaube auch. Gibt es gute deutsche Horror-Kultur aus Deutschland? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, Deutschland ist so dicht besiedelt, dass du immer das Gefühl hast, du bist relativ sicher. Aber durch dieses amerikanische, dieses weite Feld und auch so dieses Texas Chainsaw Massacre, wo du halt, du rennst schreiend durch den Wald und du denkst, okay, mich hört niemand. In Deutschland denkst du immer so, ich könnte jetzt hier schreiend rumlaufen und irgendwie Leute hören mich und es passiert was.
Aber in Amerika einfach glaube ich durch diese Einsamkeit und du weißt, wenn du
in so einem fucking Landhaus
irgendwo gefangen bist, dann hast du verloren.
Da hilft dir niemand, da kommt nicht mal jemand
bei einer Streife vorbei oder so.
Oder irgendwie Leute, du hast einfach verloren. Ich glaube, es ist einfach eine andere
Form. Ich glaube, durch diese Lehre, durch dieses Vakuum.
Das ist ein Sylt, so Rügen.
Das kann sein, so das Wattenmeer. Ja, das ist das Gruseligste in Deutschland. Stimmt, was sind denn deutsche Horrorsettings eigentlich? Also Schwarzwald, Harz, Taunus. Es gibt auch keine Western aus Deutschland. Welche Filme kommen ... Ja doch, Schwulschul ist man die tun. Ja, gut. Welche Genres kommen denn aus Deutschland eigentlich? Boah, das ist jetzt nicht so, aber ... Ja, aber das ist ja auch so, dass man die ... aus Deutschland so. Ich meine, welche Filme kommen, welche Filmsgenres? Ja doch, Schwulschul des Manitou auf jeden Fall. Ja gut, aber welche Genres kommen denn aus Deutschland eigentlich? Boah, das ist jetzt nicht so einfach. Ich glaube eher so, ja. Also eine Fritz Lang ist auch eher amerikanisch, ne? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ey, dieses Nazi-Gedöns hat echt alles kaputt gemacht, weil einfach alle die cool waren weg sind. Also ein Genre aus Deutschland? Tendenziell eher so. Welches Genre ist Deutschland bekannt? bekannt? Also eher so Arthouse. Und Porno. Arthouse? Welcher Arthouse-Film ist Deutschland? Ja, das ist ja das Ding, einen Arthouse-Film, die kennt man halt nicht. Gutes Argument. Stimmt, aber ich liebe den dänischen Arthouse-Film. Echt? Ich kann gar nicht. Ja, gut. Aber deswegen sind sie ja... Ah, die rumänische Indie-Musik, die kenne ich gar nicht. Deswegen ist ja Indie, du scheiß Arschloch. Da kann man sich so rausreden. Das verstehe ich. Ich weiß es nicht. Ach ja. Naja. Aber was nehmen wir uns jetzt noch vor? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt 101 Folgen. Ja, ist jetzt so ein bisschen Midlife-Crisis? Palindromfolge. Oh, Palindrom. Nicht unsere erste Palindromfolge, die, die Elf war schon eine Palindrom-Folge. Ja, jede Doppelzahl. Ja, das stimmt, aber 101 ist schon die coolste. Die erste dreistellige Palindrom-Folge. Geil. Wir kriegen das hin. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß bei eurem Leben. Geht mal raus, Sommer! Der Sommer ist da, genießt es, werft euch irgendwie mal die Badehose an und geht mal raus, einen schönen Tequila in der Hand.
Mein Tipp, neue Frisur. Für den Sommer eine neue Frisur ausprobieren. Einfach mal ein bisschen kürzer oder ein bisschen länger. Einfach was Neues. Einfach mal Hochsteckfrisur vielleicht. Mein Tipp, kalt duschen. Hilft sehr gut gegen die Hitze. Mein Tipp, Allergietabletten. Wenn ihr Allergie habt, nehmt Reaktin Duo,
das ist die beste Allergietablet,
die ist schön hochdosiert. Nimmst du
eine, dann hast du erst mal drei Tage keine Probleme mehr.
Mein Tipp, abwarten.
Der Sommer ist irgendwann vorbei.
Mein Tipp, Regenschirm.
Plötzliche Sommerregenschauer
können dich immer überraschen.
Nimm Regenschirm dabei, dann kann
das nicht passieren.
Mein Tipp, auf keinen Fall diese Sprühsonnencreme benutzen. Was, warum nicht? Weil die scheiße ist, weil die nicht funktioniert. Mein Tipp, Sprühsonnencreme. Ich dachte, wir sind gerade in der Rubrik Mein Tipp gibt es keine Widerrede. Kannst du einfach sagen, ich habe keine Widerrede geleistet. In der Brigitte Top Ten Sommertipps, kannst du nicht bei sieben haben, so jemanden, der dann so reinschreibt, so, äh, warum das denn, so, halt ich fresse, ich bin gerade in meinen Top-Ten-Tipps. Ja, das ist ein pluralistisches Blatt, die haben auch andere Meinungen. Das war die Rubrik Mein Tipp und das war die Folge Podcast UFO 101. Wir schaffen es ein neues Jahrhundert, das ist jetzt das zweite Jahrhundert, oder? Ja. Man weiss auch niemand so genau. Ja, ich bin stolz auf das letzte Zehntel des letzten Jahrhunderts. Ja.
Und das zwischendurch war auch mal ein gutes Zehntel.
Und das vierte Zehntel, glaube ich, war auch gut.
Und jetzt, glaube ich, müssen wir einfach dranbleiben am Ball.
Erst mal wieder ein bisschen chillen, dann wird es wieder richtig gut.
Wellenförmig.
Ja.
Ja, und natürlich auch, oh, das wollte ich auch noch mal ganz kurz sagen.
Da muss ich jetzt aber mal ganz kurz checken.
Oh, ich habe auch noch eine Sache noch auf dem Zettel.
Ganz kurz, während du das checkst,
ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm, das jetzt so zu sagen,
aber ich hoffe, ihr versteht mein Dilemma.
Also, man erstellt sich irgendwann
aus Gründen eine Facebook-Like-Seite.
Irgendwann, das kennst du bestimmt auch,
das Problem, dass irgendwann verlinken dich Leute
und es ist blöd, diese Leute nicht
mitzunehmen, wenn die das mögen, was du machst.
Deswegen erstellst du irgendwann eine Facebook-Like-Seite, damit du Leute abfangen kannst. Das Ding ist, ich habe nicht diesen Bekanntheitsgrad, dass ich das wirklich wahnsinnig rechtfertigt, dass ich da Werbung für mache und so. Und ich will auch eigentlich lieber, dass sie bei Twitter sind, weil da mache ich am meisten und bei Facebook mache ich eigentlich gar nichts. Ich kann das auch nicht so viele Seiten gleichzeitig befüllen und so. Und deswegen ist es mir unangenehm, dafür Werbung zu machen, ist mir aber auch unangenehm, so wenige Likes zu haben, weil wenn Leute mich googeln, dann denken die, ah, der ist nur so bekannt, der hat nur zwölf Likes. Also, liked meine Likes heute bei Facebook. Auch obwohl da niemals Content kommt und ihr nichts davon habt, dass du liken. Aber ich finde, das gehört dazu, das offen zuzugeben. Da wird niemals was passieren. Niemals. Ihr werdet nichts darauf finden. Einfach nur für Stefan Tietzes Ego. Genau. Es ist allein dafür, dass Leute, die mich finden, denken, ich bin bekannter als zwölf Likes. Ja. Dankeschön. Und an der Stelle möchte ich noch alle neun Hörer der dreizehnten Ordnung begrüssen. Wir wurden groß auf Spotify gefeatert mit Folge 100 und Jan Böhmann haben wir es tatsächlich geschafft, neue Hörergruppen zu erschließen und alle, die seit dem Spotify-Promo und dem grossen Hype um die hundertste Folge dazugekommen sind, sind offiziell Hörer der dreizehnten Ordnung. 12 war seit Etienne Gardets Anpreisung im Almost Daily. Elf? Folge 52. Elf seit LaCast Launch,
wahrscheinlich niemand, einfach.
Aber auf jeden Fall alle, die seit ...
Wow, die ganze Psychoanalyse-Fans.
Ich glaube, die alle rübergeschwappt sind.
Ich glaube, die elfte Ordnung ist
sehr
exklusiv, genauso wie die
dritte Ordnung, die nur Nils Ruf ist.
Aber ansonsten
seid ihr alle ... Wenn das die erste oder zweite Folge ist, die jemals vom Podcast Ruf ist. Aber ansonsten seid ihr alle,
wenn das die erste oder zweite
Folge ist, die jemals vom Podcast Ufo gehört hat, dann seid ihr
offiziell Hörer 13. Klasse.
Okay, was gut ist. Ja, absolut.
Herzlich willkommen, wir heißen euch mit
offenen Herzen willkommen.
Das war das Podcast Ufo, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten
Mal. Wenn es wieder heisst, hallo zum Podcast Ufo,
das war Florentin, Wilhelm, Stefan, Diese.
Wir heben ab.
Das war ein bisschen laut. Noch ein bisschen leiser.